taking their cues from president biden
and lobbing more smears at republicans
who were just fighting for election
integrity laws and moderate democrats
standing in the way of progressives
listen
i still feel like suddenly black people
still
are where we were under the emancipation
proclamation if they want to go down in
history as standing on the side of
segregationists and those individuals
who oppose uh people who look like me
having free and fair access to the
ballot then we will remember them as
such 16 of them as you pointed out
voted to extend the voting rights act in
2006 passed unanimously and now you
can't find a single one that will do the
same thing
it's because the republican party has
transformed to the party of fear and
fascism
but joe and the others conveniently
forgot to mention the truth on who's
really been palling around with
segregationists then senator biden once
bragged about being praised by george
wallace who once called biden a quote
outstanding young politician and biden
also once voted to restore confederate
leader jefferson davis's
u.s citizenship
greg so someone sent me an article that
uh when i got moved to the seven o'clock
cnn called me a flame thrower yes i saw
a lot of people throwing some flames at
the top of that i mean whoopi
the cnn guy i mean that that's that's
straight up nasty we have we we're now
seeing a new uh phenomenon and i've
coined it it's called on the sideism
if you don't agree with me you're on the
side of hitler if you uh oppose my tax
increase you're on the side with charles
manson if you don't put the toilet seat
down you're on the side of stalin that's
all this is now if you notice this is
the this is this the i guess the
structure of the insult now and i love
how whatever joe was demonizing
was actually always his side and it's it
kind of proves that like if you're in
politics long enough you know you will
be on the side of every issue including
now the evil side because apparently
he's he's condemning the side that he
was on as evil
you used to be on my side yes that judge
is that's exactly what he's saying yes
but but the country does the country
know that the that joe biden and the
democratic party were the party of
segregation yeah well
i i don't know if the country knows that
and that's what i worry about i think
that there are low information voters
and i think the democrats are counting
on them the people who just hear a
phrase or they just hear some celebrity
that they like you know mouthing off
about something that all of a sudden if
you don't want uh illegals to vote then
you're on the side of hitler or if you
don't show a vote if you don't show an
id proving who you really are you know
then you're on the side of you know
marxism or communism i mean they already
admit they're on the side of marxism but
communism if that could be if that's
considered worse in the end this is
really about the low information voter
you've got smart people on the right
smart people on the left the people on
the left who are smart knows it's a
bunch of hogwash the people on the right
knows it's an outright lie all right and
then they rely on the people in the
middle to get them into office but in
the end i don't know that people
remember that joe biden said hey this is
great george wallace thinks i'm terrific
or you know
uh uh strong thurman i gave eulogy of
him at his at his funeral
this is crazy and you know what's worse
i don't think joe biden remembers doing
that because i don't think he remembers
yesterday
is this a cable news situation geraldo
the president goes and calls republican
segregationists and then the very next
day
all the people on the left on cable call
the republican segregationist is this
what we're watching yeah i think it's
part that it is the the echo chamber i
think that that's right you know i've
known whoopi goldberg for decades but i
have to say that her position on this is
absolutely baloney this has not this is
an insult to the memory of the crusaders
there's nothing to do with the
emancipation proclamation of 1863 when
there was still slavery in this country
what this is about is unregulated
mail-in voting which was a function of
the covid crisis and
the voter id what's so what's the big
deal about having voter id i think as i
said yesterday everyone in this country
should have an id why is that such a big
deal why is it are are puerto ricans
inherently incapable of getting a voter
i an id i think that the federal
government should issue ids to every
american i know a lot of conservatives
don't like that too bad i think everyone
should have the same id you've got to
vote here it is at the very least
there's nothing wrong with having a
driver's license social security card
everybody's got a social security card
there should be some easy way to prove
who you are so it's not just uh you know
as if it was a car wash coupon you
receive ballots in the mail there's
three adults so you get three ballots
and then some some political operative
comes and collects them in a great big
basket i think it's bogus it really do
and it is an insult the democrats are
insulting me this has nothing to do with
bull connor has nothing to do with uh
you know strom thurmond has nothing to
do with george wallace jefferson davis
the confederacy the civil war this has
to do with common sense and each
political party vying for the position
that helps them accumulate more votes
geraldo's right dana he's not only
insulting geraldo which is just very
offensive he's insulting democrats like
senator mark kelly senator john tester
senator cinema joe manchin those are
democrats who do not want to nuke the
filibuster to pass this federal takeover
of elections
what kind of strategy is that remember
he said he would unite the country and
now he's even dividing his own party
yeah i mean that is that is something
else peralta's right on the voter id if
you look at the percentages that's like
one of the only truly bipartisan
agreements that we have in this country
is voter id so there's one thing against
him
one other thing that people don't
realize is in this bill is that it would
allow states to take this option of
spending taxpayer dollars to fund
political campaigns especially for
anybody who is able to raise a lot of
small dollar donations well guess who
that would be
aoc for example she's very good at
fundraising with small dollars marjorie
taylor green for example ted cruz has a
tweet that says why would you guys want
to give me 24 million dollars
because basically if you look at his
small dollar donations if you went six
to one is what this bill says you could
do that's incredibly unpopular all
across the country the other thing is
yesterday the president said we must
federalize elections because democracy
is at stake
and then you ask the white house what do
you think about new york allowing 900
000
non-citizens to vote in municipal
elections and they'll say oh that's just
a local issue we're not going to pay
attention to that
that doesn't make sense so the rnc the
republican national committee has sued
in new york on that very issue and also
this sort of went by me in vermont they
passed the same thing the rnc is suing
there and it's likely that because
especially in new york in our
constitution it says you must be a
citizen to vote the rnc is likely to win
on that wow something got by you dana
yeah
shocking
don't let it happen again we can't
afford it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else